The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today we're going to
conclude our study of vectors
as applied to
motion in the plane.
Now recall that for
the last two units,
we were discussing
polar coordinates.
So today what we
would like to do
is investigate what velocity
and acceleration vectors would
have looked like, had we elected
to pick representative vectors
in terms of polar coordinates.
Now what do we mean by
representative vectors?
We mean, of course,
analogs of i and j,
just like T and N in
tangential-normal components
were parallels to i and j.
Let's take a look and
see what that means here.
We call today's lecture
"Vectors in Polar Coordinates."
The idea is that
we're given a curve
C, which we have for
some reason or other
elected to express in
terms of polar coordinates.
The polar equation of the
curve C is r equals f of theta.
A typical point on
the curve C would
be called r comma theta say,
where theta was the angle made
by the horizontal and
the radius vector,
and r was the distance from
the origin to the point.
Now what we're saying
is, that in terms
of polar coordinates,
a very natural vector
to pick-- especially
if we think later
in terms of the
simple force fields
that we've talked
about earlier, the idea
that there may be a force
that has its line of action
from the origin to the
point on the curve--
a very natural vector
to choose is the vector
that we elect to call u sub r.
And what that vector
is, apparently,
is the vector 1 unit
long having the direction
of the radius vector R. So
here is u sub r over here.
If we think of u sub r
as playing the role of i,
then the vector which
plays the role of j
should be a positive
90-degree rotation of u sub r.
And we elect to call that vector
u sub theta, using the theta
here more to indicate
the fact that we're
using polar coordinates
than to indicate anything
about the angle theta itself.
In other words, notice that
u sub theta, by definition,
is just a positive 90-degree
rotation of u sub r, where
u sub r is a unit vector in the
direction of the radius vector.
Now if we want to see
this in terms of i
and j components,
what we're saying
is that u sub r is a unit vector
whose i component is what?
Since this angle
here is also theta,
its i component is cosine
theta, and its j component
is sine theta
So u sub r is cosine
theta i plus sine theta j.
u sub theta-- and I'm going
to do a little twist here
that I didn't do in
the T and N components,
just to show you
another approach.
Rather than to start with
derivatives or anything
like this, notice that what
we know about u sub theta
is that it's
obtained from u sub r
by a positive 90-degree
rotation of theta.
So that means if I replace theta
in the expression for u sub r,
by theta plus 90 degrees, that
should give me u sub theta.
If I now remember my
trigonometric identities,
that tells me that u sub
theta is minus sine theta
i plus cosine theta j.
By the way, if we now
look at this expression
and compare it with the
expression for u sub r,
we see at once that u sub theta
is the derivative of u sub
r with respect to theta.
And notice, as we said
before, that part of this
should have been
known to us by now.
Namely, since u sub
r varies with theta
but it has a constant
magnitude, we
know that the derivative of
u sub r with respect to theta
has to be perpendicular
to u sub r.
In other words, we knew
that u sub theta had
to be either plus or minus
the derivative of u sub
r with respect to
theta, but now we
have a direct way
of showing this.
And by the way, going
one step further,
if we now differentiate u sub
theta with respect to theta,
we get what?
Minus cosine theta i
minus sine theta j,
which is just minus u sub r.
In other words, if
you differentiate
u sub r with respect
to theta once,
you get u sub theta,
just as we should.
If you differentiate a second
time, you get minus u sub r.
And therefore, it appears
that the operation
of differentiating with
respect to theta rotates
u sub r by 90 degrees.
By the way, I should
mention that I
could have made all
of these remarks
when we were studying tangential
and normal components.
In other words-- I just
wrote this out here,
but this was true with T
and N. But the point was,
we never had to
differentiate N with respect
to t to find the
acceleration vector a.
In other words, recall
that the key step in using
tangential and normal
vectors-- and I'll mention this
in a little bit
more detail later--
was that the velocity
vector was simply
ds/dt times the unit tangent
vector T. The coefficient of N
was 0.
In polar coordinates,
notice that v in general
will have both a u sub r
and a u sub theta component.
Therefore, to compute a, I have
to differentiate v with respect
to t.
That means, among
other things, I'm
going to have to take
the derivative of u sub
theta with respect to t.
By the chain rule,
that's going to be
the same as taking the
derivative of u sub
theta with respect to
theta times d theta / dt.
But the important point
is, is that someplace
along the line in
studying kinematics
and polar coordinates,
I am going
to have to differentiate u sub
theta with respect to theta.
And just to show you
again very, very quickly
what I mean by
this, all I'm saying
is we already know in kinematics
that the velocity vector is
always tangential to the curve.
Notice in this
particular diagram,
for example, that if you look
at u sub r and u sub theta,
if you think of a vector
whose direction is
tangent to the curve at
this particular point,
that vector will
have, in general,
both a u sub theta and
a u sub r component.
In fact, in this
particular diagram,
I shouldn't say "in general,"
it will have u sub r and a u sub
theta component.
OK.
So far so good, but now I want
to make one little caution,
a caution which is not at all
self-evident, at least to me,
and which gave me
great difficulty myself
when I was a student.
And that is, my feeling was
that u sub r was simply the unit
vector in the direction of r.
In fact, I said that
earlier, that u sub
r was the unit vector in the
direction of the radius vector
R. And this is one of the
reasons why even though
Professor Thomas in the
textbook doesn't make such
an issue over this, why I am
such a bug on using the phrase
"sense" as well as direction.
And that is, my claim
is that the unit vector
u sub r need not be the
radius vector R divided
by the magnitude of R. It'll
have the same direction,
but watch what
happens with sense.
Instead of talking about
this thing abstractly,
let me give you a
concrete example.
Let's take the curve
which in polar coordinates
has the equation r
equals cosine theta.
OK?
As you recall, this would be
this particular circle here.
Now let's take theta
to be 120 degrees.
If I use our definition for u
sub r, which is cosine theta
i plus sine theta
j, and replace theta
by 120 degrees, what I
get is, is that u sub r
is cos 120 degrees i
plus sine 120 degrees j.
Remember that the cosine
of 120 is minus 1/2
and the sine of 120 is plus
1/2 the square root of 3.
u sub r turns out to
be minus 1/2 i plus 1/2
the square root of 3 j.
On the other hand, my claim is
that when theta is 120 degrees,
what point are we at the curve?
You see, if I take
theta to be 120
degrees-- notice that
when theta is 120 degrees,
r is negative 1/2.
And that therefore I'm
at the point P_0 here.
Recall that by definition,
R, the radius vector,
is measured from the
origin to the point.
In other words, according
to our previous definition,
it's this vector,
which would be called
R. But our definition
says that it's
this vector, which is u sub r.
And in fact, if you
just check the figures
that we've obtained
over here, notice
that u sub r has its i
component equal to minus 1/2,
its j component being plus
1/2 the square root of 3.
Therefore x is negative.
y is positive.
But if x is negative
and y is positive,
you're in the second quadrant,
not the fourth quadrant.
You see?
In other words, u sub r is
almost the radius vector.
In fact, it would have been,
if in polar coordinates,
little r happened
to be positive.
In fact, let me summarize
that in a different way.
Let's assume that we have a
curve C whose polar equation
is r equals f of theta.
Then the idea is this.
If f of theta happens to
be at least as big as 0,
then u sub r is equal
to the radius vector
R divided by its magnitude.
In other words, u sub r will
be in the same direction
as the radius vector.
And by the way, recall this is
just another way of saying r.
What we're saying is
again, if we had never
let little r in polar
coordinates be negative,
no problem would have occurred.
But we do let little
r be negative.
So we have to be a mite careful.
The careful part comes in where?
If r happens to be negative.
In which case, u sub r
has the opposite sense
of the radius vector
capital R, which
we saw in the previous example.
In other words, in
this case, u sub r
is the negative of
the radius vector
divided by its magnitude.
In what case is that?
If r happens to be negative.
The important point to notice,
however, that in either case,
the radius vector R is equal to
the polar coordinate r times u
sub r.
In other words, if r
happens to be positive,
these two vectors
have the same sense.
If r happens to be
negative, these two vectors
have the opposite sense.
In other words, in either
case, this expression
is always correct.
But the important
thing to notice
is that the sense of u sub r
is determined by theta, not
by r, not by f of theta.
OK?
At any rate, once we have this
particular recipe established,
we can now go ahead and
study motion in the plane.
Namely, notice that
our radius vector
R is now given by the polar
coordinate r times u sub r.
Or I guess I should
say here that I'm
assuming that the
equation of motion
is given by r is some
function of theta.
That's the r that
I'm using in here.
At any rate, what is
the velocity vector?
By definition, it's just the
derivative of the radius vector
with respect to time.
That's just d/dt
of r times u sub r.
Now keep in mind,
that r and u sub r
are both functions
of time-- namely,
the distance of the
particle from the origin
as well as the direction
of the line of action
that joins the
particle to the origin
will, in general,
depend on time.
Consequently, I must use
the product rule here.
I already know that I can use
the product rule for vector
and/or scalar functions and
any combination thereof.
So I just differentiate this
thing with respect to time.
I get what?
This is dr/dt-- in other
words, the derivative
of the first times the
second, which is u sub r, OK?
Plus the first
times the derivative
of the second, which
is the derivative of u
sub r with respect to time.
Now keep in mind,
again, there is
nothing wrong with this recipe.
But what I would like is to have
the velocity expressed in u sub
r and u sub theta components.
So far, I have it expressed
in terms of u sub r component
and a d(u sub r)/dt component.
But now, here again is why the
chain rule is so important.
Keep in mind that I already know
that if this expression here
had been the derivative
of u sub r with respect
to theta instead of
with respect to t,
what would this
expression have been?
It would have been u sub theta.
We solved that earlier
in the lecture.
Well, here's what we do.
We say, OK, these
aren't the same.
But let's cross this out.
Let's use the chain rule.
And by the chain
rule, the derivative
of u sub r with respect to t
is the same as the derivative
of u sub r with respect to
theta-- times d theta / dt.
And rewriting this so
that it becomes legible,
we have that the velocity vector
is dr/dt times u sub r plus r d
theta / dt times u sub theta.
And again notice that as
far as u sub r and u sub
theta are concerned, even if
I did not notice my subtlety--
and by the way, I'm going to
leave this for the exercises--
but even if I didn't notice the
subtlety that u sub r need not
have the same sense as the
radius vector r-- notice
that if I did not try to
draw this thing to scale,
I can still get the-- I
shouldn't have said the scale--
but if I didn't try to
graph the answer here given
r as a function of theta and
theta is a function of t,
notice that dr/dt
and r d theta / dt
are well-defined arithmetically
with no possible chance
of making a geometrical mistake.
The place that you can
make the biggest mistake
is if you automatically
think that u sub r must
have the same sense as
capital R. But as I say,
we'll leave any
additional discussion
of that for the exercises.
I should also point
out that when I first
learned this recipe
myself, it turned out
that we were ahead of--
the physics class was ahead
of the math class.
And we learned this thing
in the physics class
almost intuitively.
In other words, as
a geometric aside,
notice that if I'm
given the curve
and say s indicates the
direction of increasing arc
length here, what I could do is
think of a little differential
region here.
Namely, here's my
radius vector r,
and here's my velocity vector
in the direction of u sub r.
Then I take a little
increment of angle d theta,
and I now think of v sub
theta, which is at right angles
to v sub r, as being tangent
to the circle I would have
obtained if I had imagined
that this particular point--
the particle was being viewed
with respect to the circle
rather than to the curve itself.
To make a long story
short, what I'm driving at
is that physically,
it's very easy
to justify that the
magnitude of the u sub r
component of the velocity
is the magnitude of dr/dt--
how fast the radius vector
is changing instantaneously.
On the other hand, notice that
for the u sub theta component,
this arc length is given in
differential form by r d theta.
If I divide the arc length
by the time, which is dt,
I get r d theta divided by dt,
which leads to r d theta / dt,
which is the same expression
that we got analytically.
But the point that I
want to bring out here
is that our derivation required
no geometrical physical
insight.
And the reason that I
want to bring this out
is I followed this argument
fine in my elementary physics
course.
The place I got hung up is
that the instructor then went
into a fantastic hand-waving
type of demonstration
and showed us how the
acceleration looked
in terms of u sub r and
u sub theta components.
And actually, that
was a blessing for me,
because it was that
day that I decided
to become a math major
rather than a physics
major, which was a blessing both
for me and society, I guess.
But the thing that
I want to show you
is that the beauty of
our mathematical approach
is that we can now obtain
a, the acceleration vector,
from the velocity vector
without having to know
any great physical insight.
In fact, we have to know no
physical insight to do this.
Namely, by definition, a is
the derivative of the velocity
vector with respect to time.
We also have seen
that the velocity
vector is the expression
that I have here in brackets.
So I have to differentiate
that with respect to time.
Notice that this is the sum
of two terms, one of which
is a product of two factors,
and the other of which
is a product of three factors.
And by the way, among other
things to review here,
this is the first
time in this course
that we have actually
had to use the product
rule for a function consisting
of three variable factors.
Even though we discussed
this in part one,
here is a case where in
a real-life situation,
what we need is the derivative
rule for a product of three
functions.
At any rate, this is done
in great detail in the text.
I do it more in the notes.
So I'm just going to
hit the highlights here.
The point is I now differentiate
this sum term by term.
Namely, to differentiate
this, I take
the derivative of the
first term times the second
plus the first term times
the derivative of the second.
Now to differentiate
this term, I
have to differentiate a
product of three factors.
And recall-- and by the way,
as I told you in part one,
whenever I say "recall," that
means if you don't recall,
it's my polite way of
saying, "look it up."
But to differentiate a
product of three functions,
we write the product
down three times,
and each time differentiate
a different factor.
For example, the
first time we'll
differentiate r with respect
to t, which is dr/dt.
The second time,
we'll differentiate
d theta / dt with
respect to t, which
is the second derivative
of theta with respect to t.
And the third time,
we'll differentiate
u sub theta with respect to t,
which is the derivative of u
sub theta with respect to t.
And summarizing that,
what do I have here?
I have dr/dt d theta / dt times
u sub theta plus r d^2 theta /
dt squared times u sub theta
plus r d theta / dt times
the derivative of u sub
theta with respect to t.
Now the point is that if I
look at these five terms,
some of them are in nice form.
Namely, here's a u sub r term.
Here's a u sub theta term.
But these terms are
sort of mongrelized.
Namely, what I have to do here
is utilize the chain rule.
And remember that the
derivative of u sub
r with respect to theta
would have been u sub theta.
The derivative of u sub
theta with respect to theta
would have been minus u sub r.
So by the chain
rule-- you see what
I'm going to do is, I'll
replace each of these terms
by their chain rule expression.
Then I'll collect terms.
And the reason I'm
going over this
fairly rapidly is that it is
a problem of sheer mechanics.
But the punch line is that
if I now collect my terms,
the acceleration vector has as
its u sub r component d^2 r /
dt squared minus r d
theta / dt squared.
And the u sub theta component is
r d^2 theta / dt squared plus 2
dr/dt d theta / dt.
And the beautiful
part, from my point
of view about all
of this, is if I
don't understand
any physics at all,
this particular result is valid.
It's mathematically
self-contained.
Now certainly there
is no harm in a man
who understands physics well
enough to say, look at it.
This is the acceleration in
the radius direction alone.
And this is some kind of a
correction factor proportional
to the square of the
angular velocity, see,
d theta / dt being angular
velocity and what have you.
And go through this
particular thing.
I'm saying fine,
if you can do that.
But notice the beauty.
This complicated
expression gives us
the acceleration vector in
terms of u sub r and u sub
theta with no hand-waving.
It's mathematically
self-contained.
And by the way, keep
in mind that one
of the reasons that we study
polar coordinate motion
is the fact that,
in many cases, we
are going to be dealing
with a central force field.
And the interesting thing
is that in a central--
I'll just abbreviate this--
in a central force situation,
this expression is 0.
See, central force means what?
That the force is in
the radial direction.
That means all of
the acceleration--
if you're using
Newtonian physics,
F equals ma-- all
the acceleration is
in the direction of u sub r.
Therefore, the component in
the direction of u sub theta
must be 0.
So this fairly
complicated expression--
r d^2 theta / dt squared plus
2 dr/dt d theta / dt equals 0
becomes the fundamental equation
for central force field motion.
But again, we'll talk about
that more in the exercises.
What I wanted to do now
was to make what I think
is a very important summary.
And that is that when we're
studying the position vector
R, and the velocity vector v,
and the acceleration vector a,
that none of these depend
on the coordinate system.
It's only their
components that do.
In other words, at
the expense of having
a fairly jumbled figure which I
rationalize here-- it is small,
but I think it is
clear from context.
What I'm saying is, let's
suppose I have a curve C,
and some point P_0
on this curve C.
I can draw in the pair
of orthogonal vectors
i and j in the plane.
I can draw in the pair
of orthogonal vectors
u sub r-- "orthogonal"
means perpendicular,
if we haven't said that before--
u sub r and u sub theta.
I can draw those in.
And I can draw in
T and N. Now all
I know is that if I have
the velocity vector v,
it must be tangential
to the curve.
Hopefully by this time, we
realize that the acceleration
vector has no such restriction.
Let's just draw in a v and an a,
call these the velocity vectors
and the acceleration vectors.
The point is that v and a are
determined by the motion--
not by the coordinate system.
In other words, when we're
talking about the velocity
of this particle at the point
P:0, its velocity is the same,
no matter what coordinate
system we're using.
It just happens that
if we're dealing
with Cartesian coordinates,
the velocity vector
is dx/dt i plus dy/dt j.
In other words, it's this
particular combination
of i and j.
If we're using T
and N components,
the particular combination
of T and N is what?
ds/dt times the unit
tangent vector plus 0 N.
And if we happen to be
using polar coordinates,
the expression is dr/dt * u
sub r plus r * d theta / dt
* u sub theta.
But let me circle
these, because it's
the same velocity in each case.
We use this when horizontal and
vertical motion are important.
We use this when we're
interested in motion
along the curve.
And we use this primarily
in central force fields.
But it makes no difference.
It's the same velocity vector.
And in a similar way, it's also
the same acceleration vector,
whichever system
you happen to use.
Namely, if we use
Cartesian coordinates,
the acceleration vector
is the second derivative
of x with respect to t times i
plus the second derivative of y
with respect to t times j.
That same vector, if we express
it in T and N components,
is d^2 s / dt squared
times T, plus kappa,
the curvature number, times
ds/dt squared times N.
And if we express it in
terms of polar coordinates,
as we just saw earlier
in our lecture,
this is the expression
that we get.
In other words then,
this summarizes our study
of motion in the plane
using either Cartesian
or polar or tangential
and normal components.
You see, the point is
that we pick whichever
coordinate system happens to be
of the greatest interest to us,
the greatest value to us.
We make the coordinate
system our slave,
rather than the
other way around,
and tackle the problem from
that particular point of view.
At any rate, that ends this
phase of our particular course.
And in the next
phase of our course,
we get to probably what is
the most fundamental building
block of the entire course.
We get to that
particular topic which,
by and large, most courses in
functions of several variables
begin with.
But we'll talk about that
more the next time we meet.
And until that time, goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.